my god that's Jason Bourne why were to  come back now I know who I am  I remember everything remembering  everything doesn't mean you know  everything tell me the world is a bore  we need the perfect weapon we're gonna  be g13 I Know Who I am we have finished  with you you'll no longer be it yourself  I remember I remember everything  remembering everything doesn't mean you  know everything  tell me we've just been hacked could be  worse than Snowden facial recognition  got it hit Jesus Christ that's Jason  Bourne  why would to come back now  there's a demonstration in front of the  Greek parliament building I think she'll  use it as cover  interactive we got a move  he's same things he knows things what if  he's not coming for us what if it's  something else I volunteered me because  of a lie this is Jason Bourne I need to  talk  32 kills people are safer because of  what you did  you're never gonna find any piece not  till you admit to yourself who you  really are my god that's